[Music]
a few years ago most supermodels looked
exactly the same tall beautiful and
physically flawless but these days
photographers and modeling agencies
actually prefer models who go against
the grain with their unique features and
unconventional beauty if you're ready to
see ten of the most unusual models who
are changing the fashion industry please
subscribe to our channel and give this
video a big thumbs up mafi most girls
are rejected in the modeling industry
because of their flaws but not Muffy
when the people at store modeling agency
took one look at her they knew she was a
winner Mafia's cross-eyed but that
hasn't stopped her from taking the
modeling world by storm photographers
have been lining up for a chance to
photograph her and her unusual
appearance
Alex Minsky retired Marine corporal Alex
Minsky looks like your typical male
model he has a handsome face and a
chiseled body covered in tattoos but
when Alex was 21 he was riding in a
vehicle during his first tour of
Afghanistan when it hit a roadside bomb
his right leg was amputated and to cope
with the mental and physical trauma
he began hitting the gym he was
discovered by a fashion photographer
during one of his gym sessions and the
rest is history
alex has since gone on starring ads for
big-name designers including Calvin
Klein Laura O'Grady when Laura O'Grady
was growing up kids would always tease
her about her large and protruding ears
but years later it was her unique
appearance that would make her the talk
of the modelling industry so 5 10
unconventional beauty has landed gigs
with footwear brand ugh and she has
graced the pages of clash magazines
Sean Ross Sean Ross is the modeling
industry's first male albino model he
began modeling when he was just 16 and
he's one of the many who have helped
anti cookie cutter models reach the
forefront of the industry Sean says he's
aware his smile isn't the prettiest and
his face is a little disoriented but his
unique look is a challenge for
photographers to capture and they just
can't get enough of him
he has appeared in music videos for
beyonce and katy perry and he has
modelled for luxury brands such as
alexander mcqueen and g boshy daphne
self the modeling industry was once
obsessed with youth age and beauty but
all changed by the time Daphne south was
88 years old she had already modeled for
Dolce & Gabbana and Ralph Lauren and she
doesn't plan on slowing down anytime
soon
she's Britain's oldest runway model and
she's letting the younger girls know she
still has what it takes to strut down
the catwalk like a pro Lia T Lia T is a
beautiful fashion model who was born a
man being openly transgender wasn't
always easy for her and she said she
always felt different even as a child
thankfully her parents supported her
decision to have a gender reassignment
surgery in March 2012 and she also found
an unlikely support system in for maji
maji creative director Riccardo Tisci
Lia started off as Ricardo's assistant
before she was hired to pose in the
brand's ad campaign she has also been
featured in magazines such as Vanity
Fair and Vogue Paris Kacey Legler when
KC Legler friend convinced her to
participate in a photo shoot for Muse
magazine she was all for it that's right
KC's a woman who exclusively models
menswear clothing standing at 6 foot 2
tall with her gorgeous cheekbones and
piercing eyes Casey has been able to
bend gender stereotypes in the modeling
world by signing to the men's division
of prestigious board modeling agency
winning Harlow while attending school
winning Harlow's classmates would call
her names such as cow and zebra due to a
skin condition called vitiligo the
condition caused patches of pale skin
around her mouth hands
torso and knees and the bullying got so
bad she even considered taking her own
life when he eventually dropped out of
school and was later discovered on
Instagram by America's Next Top Model
host Tyra Banks when he appeared on the
twenty first cycle of the show in 2014
and although she was eliminated from the
competition
her modeling career took off she has now
walked in numerous runway shows and has
clothes for glamour and Complex magazine
Ric Jeunesse Christian s also known as
zombie bored began transforming his body
at the age of 16 by covering his face
and torso with tattoos his body ain't
caught the attention of Lady Gaga's
fashion director and Rick was asked to
appear in the singers music video for
forum this way you would think someone
who has tattooed as a living skeleton
wouldn't have much success in the
modelling industry but that hasn't been
the case for Rick she is modeled for
designing Fairy Mugler and
also featured in an issue of GQ style
Molly Bayer
Molly Bayer was peaceful looking like an
alien when she was growing up but her
unusual features and appearances caught
the eye of the modeling industry and
Molly is now laughing in the faces of
all her haters she signed with elite
London and has put her dreams of
majoring in computer science on the back
burner Molly still can't believe how
popular she has become in the industry
and she told CNN I would never think
that a girl who spent most of her
childhood with a unibrow glasses and a
Yoda shirt would be in vogue italia
which is these unusual models inspired
youth most react in the comments section
down below and don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up
[Music]